[Applaudissements]
cette semaine c'est très mystérieux je
voulais résumé ça vient en photo parce
que je pense être tombé sur des photos
que qu'elle n'a pas même l de lézat
passer votre âme à vas-y vas-y on adore
la première les bébés elle est née à 16
décembre on dira pas l'année mais c'est
pas trop mignon ça les craquantes
mais moi je n'ai pas cette photo ob bâle
alors après la vie non pas parce que les
personnes à cette foutue gens qui
étaient sans papa on voit son papa le
petit france ou français on va papa
c'est vrai il est bourré pourquoi on
l'appelle france au bain pensent que
parce qu'il s'appelait françois c est
son deuxième prénom alphonse françois et
du coup les gens n'a pu l'accepter son
surnom est jamais de sa maman oui côté
parents louis s'était donné une
droguerie à lyon ah ouais ça plaît
la droite de souris il un grand bazar
qui faisait tout le tour comme ça il y
avait plein de grandes vitrines ils ré
cette photo doc cette photo non pas
parce que je te dise alors se faisait
traiter de l'anecdote c'est là où elle a
eu son sa première aventure sexuelle
avec feel it son premier amour oh non
non
oh non c'est vraiment lui meiway mehdi
bennani les gosses au là-dessus même à
l'arrêt dès débats
il a deux dents il avait des trucs mais
ils étaient mignons surtout il me
faisait beaucoup rire il avait beaucoup
d'humour
c'est lui le premier mec totten way et
non mais du vénitien ça c'est ma grand
mère anna satie l'a pas non plus et son
grand père gaston excusez moi ta
cambrioler chez dell ou pas mais son
grand père à gaz commandé 120 pages web
c'est non c'est bizarre ça qui aurait pu
donner ça parce que en fait ils sont
super ça donnait ça
à moins que j'ai trouvé donné on peut
revoir les photos
ouais merci pas la première vas-y la
première communion adolf hitler
adolf hitler mais chez vous son papa
sonar ou non jeu savamment oh là là oui
c'est normal
oui ça va bien non madame à lembras on
sait pas qui sort sa grand-mère à leurs
proches et bernadette soubirous non et
oui il son grand père il était jeune
mais c'est buffalo bills danois pas moi
ah non non mais c'est pas con pas lieu à
l'époque ça j'allais ou pas ben voila
merci lolo baies vitrées
[Applaudissements]